good afternoon it's an honor to welcome
it were the sort of the more the
laureate of the 2,000
11 Pritzker Prize of architecture known
as the noble of architecture to this
event sponsored by sepa and columbia
world leaders forum last June the second
President Obama presented the Pritzker
Prize to Eduardo Souto Mora and place
him for creating buildings that inspired
us and for a style that seems effortless
as it's beautiful Eduardo Souto Mora has
a unique talent too much beauty with
simplicity from the citation of the jury
of the pritzker prize is where de Soto
Mora architecture is not obvious
frivolous or picturesque it's imbued
with intelligence and seriousness his
work requires an intense intense
encounter not a quick glance and like
poetry it's able to communicate
emotionally to those who take time to
listen in the last 20 years Portugal has
produced three world-class talents al
ver si se va de Souza saramago the
laureate of the 99 nobel prize for
literature and with where do so tomorrow
it's the second time the Pritzker Prize
is awarded to approach is in the last 20
years only Japan has more Pritzker Prize
laureates than Portugal which is truly
amazing given that it's a small country
with so many problems I just stopped at
Columbia book start and brought to
Eduardo blindness by josie saramago the
laureate of the 99 nobel prize for
literature and notes on sensitive
architecture by alvar cesar the laureate
of the 92 Prisca price other than their
talent Saramago alvaro siza and it also
tamura have something in common none of
them is from lisbon and they are all
political from the left
he's wearin a certain water was born and
lives in Oporto known as the invincible
city and his office in the same street
and in the same building as that of
álvaro siza oporto is that city in the
world with the highest number of pisgah
Prize laureates per capita I invited it
whether to give a lecture at Columbia
exactly one week before he came to the
u.s. to receive the Pisgah price from
president obama honestly I never
imagined that you would accept because
he is an extremely busy busy person and
the world start but he answer to my
invitation I like the idea I like
Columbia therefore I accept your
invitation and I'll fix a tight as soon
as I came back from the award ceremony
we have not talked again until yesterday
but there was no need for that because
it Waldo is not only a great architect
but a wonderful person we are leaving a
turning point for the first time ever
half of the world population lives in
cities for the first time in more than
five centuries the West is losing its
dominance non-oecd countries are rapidly
approaching fifty percent of what GDP
when 30 years ago they represented only
twenty-five percent there are 20 cities
in the world with more than 10 million
evidence of which only two in the US and
Europe all this represents a historic
transition great part of our future
depends on how cities will develop not
so much in the West but in the rest of
the world we need the contribution of
architects with the vision and the
talent of Eduardo Souto Mora not only to
create beautiful spaces to live but also
to help help us crossing this historic
transition so without further ado I have
the honor to introduce is Waldo so
tamura the laureate of the 2011 Prisca
price
but that good evening this was my good
focus Portuguese it's easy for me I'm
sorry but probably have thank you so
much for this invitation via what for me
it's a great pleasure to be here at this
university I'd like to thank dr. Manuel
opinion it them who convey invited me
personally to come here where I've been
here before a few years back at the
invitation of Kenneth Renton with us
when I was invited I immediately said
yes exactly and the fact that I find
friends of mine here old friends of mine
it's makes it even more pleasant books
though a second issue Philippa little
boots I'd like to talk about them when
we talk about the architecture of the
future the city of the future they asked
me to say a few works I'm not concerned
about the future but the transition to
the future I'm worried about sometimes
the future is take so fast to get that
what most concerns me is the president
when I have to do in the present like
that and what I'm doing so architecture
through history that has an element of
continuity and then there are certain
ruptures with which they write with the
but they don't occur with traditional
but they don't occur overnight so the
vanguards of all are dated by the
historians in a single date however they
occur that his history of architecture
is a lower the history Casa is one of
the most conservative the home is one of
the most conservative houses are one of
the most conservative institutions
possible the other day I was in each
other and I looked up new a house in
Mesopotamia a vmware for info
and there was a constructor that was
almost identical to housed inside a
fishbowl in other words through the Pope
the architecture changes little dated
the highest the house has certain
inertia with it without propia and an
identity that changed the materials may
change that the technique Smith of
construction may change but the the
morphology the shape changes little so
forth if it weren't that way yes unless
better the castle if we were waiting for
always winner for the house of the
future or not the the astronauts
eddakath would have no desire to come
back on so over the wall represent that
about what I will show you I don't want
to split sling them I know we're going
to have a question and answer evo fouls
per se i'm just going to show you a few
my paws on that and then i'll jump
forward to the tail projects official
last house I work to work out there am I
is a house in Maya via fate the English
lock it's done on to lots of land you do
a lot 12 the bike as about you it's a
patio house on patho metal here's the
subway that which the train which makes
a lot of noise it's closed out of the
vasa we have these walls MacArthur thing
the house has two meses volumes to
gardens yet without the fan did the
entrance system near the vegetables near
the area where the where there the
separation between the two areas we have
we see here the tomb at one of the two
York's all day area with the living room
and the kitchen and an interior garden
and I cool fine here's another entrance
in center and the bedrooms and here is
the guard a for the bedrooms it's in the
climb but it's love it inclines towards
this direction should be under this
Guardian
is the pool you follow the mightiness a
collage of the mill and the engineering
of the room to take advantage of that
garden here you can see the profile but
like how the rear of the house if
there's a part about this is a more
mobile door well that gives access as
soon as the engineer and generally what
the of the pool here's the pool with an
hour a window here here when we catch of
a low that's the only window in the
house and in the back of what that value
here that is they get next to a large
dream look at the Luna kept the in
cattle uma f baby one tree means URL of
that if they're too you shouldn't go in
if the better battery this marble block
is almost a decoration over the door it
adds a certain modern ability it's
Italian and it also indicates where the
door is Ponte to Abbeville and then we
go through the door and inside well
that's the pair here we see this block
of marble same marble but they are
thought the marble goes through to the
living room dhawal it goes around
without follow and here is the fallback
living room at the oven they thought I
followed is would be here but a
fireplace where the fireplace would be
here this is the living room this would
be where this is where the school is
developer and windows which can be
accomplished in which can allow asleep
if these are Swiss windows made in
portugal 11 they opened outside TOA and
it's a lot of mail is Sheena where it's
fed would spring water dorval Umbra here
is a tree for shower yeah and a window I
that image failure to multiplication up
people soda side of the Atlantic at
Warwick they also sleep about not as
attractive so
abella sometimes there's a negative
aspect my walls million but I think
there are no ugly on skates what their
law while good and bad photographers
good and bad architects cupola casa del
Bravo durian is the client himself the
the he did wood construction he
dedicated it up tremendously to
constructing this house you can see here
with this tangent line from above yep
what that meant that young people to
oppose it continues all the way to the
lower dollar but I was but the headline
there is a separation of materials here
when working with wood and all the
figure these yes bad if joints in your
part and this is done but if they think
that i had 45 degrees here a lot of
squats pool here are the bedroom in the
bedroom area with the garment the
bedroom won't go by rickie we want this
break here i'll make up for the others
evolutive and here is the opening you
get that will clap hands volunteers the
main bedroom with a bed would be half of
it you can see the garden through the
mirror as all of the cuisine that here
is the kitchen area Achilles where the
light the light continues all the way
down this way here we see the detail
level and the negative space that
receives the light is the negative space
where you have the curtain both of the
optivisor here is the bathroom with a la
tavola and a mirror a gift well on this
side be able to rip them back we can
send a methods but a small near here
also which helps to do materialize the
frame about female a model the finishing
touches in marble they travel to this
what is the service of us for the fake
up but toward that comes from the garage
he
visioneer a light a double light a
partner but now for this little war does
either we didn't want a very heavy door
filled with ox here so it's it's
elevated the doorknob has elevated
rooted in a relief lay here go to
benefit found validation the zoning laws
don't allow for very high walls so I had
to cut it here be a public and I took
advantage of this for a little spring if
you'd only of the Catholic parochial and
finally the doghouse a Nepali of the
nature in has invaded in swimming at the
beach but yeah this was my first
experience in building as a child in
concealed weapon Torah here there is a
brewskis ranger who lives in if they
were in London and I had the opportunity
to choose the land this is a city near
lisboa and for a museum representing the
stars I choose this area where the
museum the ocean museum already exists
the museo de menthe yet I want keep cool
bespoke optic it was nervous too crowded
home yep that will sell from before the
Revolution Amitabha 40 it was ill and
nagawaukee and this museum I had just
finished metal deport working on the
portal Metro with our subway fight where
I had to prove it out do something for
the actual stations and using elevations
and I had to cut a few trees topical
drama so I was traumatized by the
experience when I had to go to
psychologist and the fact that I had to
remove so many trees their side tried 10
mil years later a prey to make up for it
I pude definitely 200 to make up for it
but even then insulted me for the local
fit so this has given use your know
survival so then I began the student
work I chose this area this was where
the tennis courts were so popular
practically closed by the trees we have
al cafe and I decidedly to create a why
would be the negative of a true benefit
and I told myself I'm not going to touch
these trees though echo player so I
found this shake yet on polk will get
beautiful which was rather than negative
ad fill out video here there would be a
patio with these wear these trees are
located hey Erica the idea was hope of
gaseous who creates a set blocks loud
and what's the one question Robert well
with the Viera an elevator love of
center which would be where the lava
temporary exhibits BFFL about these
trees here would be like a portico I
think of the lividity and here we would
have the bookstore the restaurant you'll
see in the auditorium provide a solid
you would basically it would be like you
would walk through Jesus exhibit rooms
and they would be at different heights
until you get to the anticipation
circuit form what are the thoughts the
people Apollo here it were inspired by
paulo de gusoff painted and work at
holla the idea was that across you would
find out support the use of these doors
and windows to tie the blocks together
as links well i think that i look here's
the entrance apart the receiving area
here's a video a door to the bookstore
boys thought I and here the restroom
locked up in here the door leading to
the exhibit the temporary exhibits a
paratha entrance after that through the
trip which column here you can see it by
the size of the government but the
mobility was under he would be hidden it
so I needed a vertical element that
would highlight it so I opted for these
towers babyrage had a high ceiling but I
forgot ah Fievel made it so that they
can stand out from the these masses of
Trudy's blocks of trust
that reason behind entrance taking
advantage of this natural entrance to
the trees and here the oval there's the
entrance that announces the museum the
two pyramids well the sexual plan the
blueprint and here's the circuit you
would walk through it and go back to the
beginning the opana evening Gotham
Museum doing clay closed off the doors
and the auditorium and the bookstore in
the restaurant are it's still elephant
with water there's a patio where you can
eat outdoors observation but here is the
service again see that and here the
fifth the cost we have football we had
to those blessed elevate it to object
above a tree service and to give a
certain Hyatt editor to image to the
museum itself what well here we see a
linear scale yet akali dal made them and
it's an increasing scale sending City
back well there's a to diminish the
impact a lot of the contemporary art
museum specially it without a thickness
for temporary exhibits but we don't know
what will be there we wanted to create a
certain mobility inside we can even have
a crocodile on the floor that either the
entrance may be able no diagonal lives
out here we see the to trace well like
he missed this is a pipe a portico aisle
to order / people laughing it's written
that they're not worth you have the
dates when it was founded day and be
there for a year the fact that I chose
to chewed without the deep red was
precisely to create a contrast with
green apples together when it's
surrounded by liquid sure that the color
contrasts will the trees vennela here is
the taglish them a one of the rules of
the museum is that every division had a
window looking out so never forget
really that a reality it okay Phil to
you they wouldn't so that they would
never feel close look for the
claustrophobic I am claustrophobic
myself
the thought of this is the book store
window give him that here we see the
newer jury so Phil and what happened was
a coup columbiasc a hour when i arrived
at the workplace of for worksite Smith
and the shaker while they needed people
only get the powers of that positive and
negative spaces that contrast to the
trees and they hit out cut almost all
the trees move so i was there in the
middle of the work site and i asked them
you know Judith and the
environmentalists who used to would say
there's out of that you can't cut the
trees your feathers I've had cut the
trees the same little Dickie that they
were not released from the area's racism
because it's that those trees are not
from this area is only I had two
opposite ask the president of the
chamber that is a shame you with weather
at the city hall to plant trees as fast
as poss what did I 52 I most to me here
to apathy ad what's the polite n by if
you look close no exaggeration to sweep
it for the matter if they're not that is
but you spotted become quite welcome we
read fans and here is the restaurant
with our here is a bellyful room give a
premier you film rest and look out site
but the Eiffel a materials are not
affected what you thought America it is
a theater betha the concrete is mixed
with a very red it's a red actual rare
stone from the area that red grape
escape it's called a zoological sky this
is the name of the stone from the reject
at work probably the contrast color
you're not only creates a contrast it
was so awful to the green ultra-safe
blood but i did a chest for
my office without putting on stone
against this out in the Sun to seafood
favor gravity cat food it faded a little
bit and I liked it because it looks like
this older a type of architecture from a
great architect who I loved is that far
from the end of the chat last year to
churn last century and I like the Eels
too and i used the angles that are
evocative of that those buildings here
and here those are the bolt lava on the
other side shipping looks out to the
gala it's less their palette at least
it's the administrative officer was that
a plague off you and the teaching spaces
i'll give it a tier the bookstore for
that level FEMA here is a multi-party
study area and auditorium without a
restaurant but what garish palette but
what kid this is a small room for small
well-made home with all the media
maintenance here's the rest here yes
with a bench they insisted on putting
that paintings there to the web de novo
call by ish idea of pain what a
mentality renton of oh he's mentality of
the mountains all over the place over
here gilfillan where people could sit at
the bench and look at if katha and rest
no service you'll melt before Blair I
kill but in de lis wouldn't rather them
you can't see but yet we got for you
can't see well outside but this is
there's there's actually a pipe I think
he's from the sealian comes through here
lovely it's not real a pretty here the
interior planning the vehicle out of
where that tree stood it was like he
landed here we see light coming through
diva it's a built-in waddle and it's
regulated according to
pushing them the absinthe it could it
could work at thirty fifty or hundred
percent brightness up there are no
spotlights no direct lights but that way
to be there on the pedals so we
eliminated a generally not but if but
this natural light of you that
illuminates the window with the exact
same almost exact same brightness on
this side and that side it's very
graduated actually have with a felon
here we are good idea in the a temporary
exhibit room and where the light is at a
hundred percent which is difficult to
really illuminate well from here to here
but it's all done without artificial
lighting a fatal but here's the exit
where there's a bulge a lot of students
come and the suspect a double z line
throughout the teachers can sit down
their students to explain and the end
they can sit them down to see if they
are still there with you pull that the
back of a line but if this is lost that
because this looks like a shock to you
through a source but where the end today
we're asking what the hell is this
number thought his report this is a
tower in portal
well
gosh case i think is this machine okay
thank you mr. Mohammed neither can ii
the mayor the city at the port of a
dissenter omar y le gasp ow autostrada
clatters boa you did stress dreams yes
the three fate will be the same
principle now yes sis pon back to yes
yes what steps is the first on Brazil
aid in commander for every metal mania
owner and Jennifer another one for a
Brazilian aware what I decided to do was
a low ceiling which is why i'm building
you know we are and another taller
building a tower in New York we talk
about towers well it has 25 floors and
walk away it's in a recess there are
some stairways and there is a Plaza in
the middle the measures are 27 x 27 we
started to the project is seagull I
wanted siga my colleague and friend that
already built the these buildings in the
same proportion and between the three
buildings wala Plaza a get speaker and
then another building outside and there
is a bridge so we have a platen 2+3
plazas and people can walk around in
distress in this pathway there was a
bidding yeah won the bidding in Austria
to build a casino and we were walking
through the Baracus
l area and we were inspired by the
designer my friends project was not sold
but mine was sold we have another
project showing the towers buccleuch
applies we see here to central core
areas if it's an official they are
structural the year but say it has the
structure why starting by the facade I
like to work on the facade structure
because it gives me a certain discipline
and from there I continue with the
composition so that the finished product
is completely autonomous so we have the
tower the stairwells every room and the
plaza and of course this was planned
with the size the proportion and the
height was done thinking on the was done
by the fire fighters and the food with
my engineers the structure couldn't go
beyond 32 centimeters so I had to build
a building wavy proportions already set
up that was not in line with the
architectural my credential tradition it
was a system of progression mechanism
addition of where it doesn't matter
whether you have more or less of this
and that and so we will file that
pallets I wanted to show what the
pallets do and what is their function
they have a base what is it a very fair
that can be in wood or in iron or
concrete with the fifth stone and then
the architect soccer moms the several
layers and then we have the
the olive on top of the over as a crown
I submitted to the bank the final
project and they told me that it didn't
make sense she said something so pompous
and I was Sabbath with that and I turned
it into a closet for my house and
fortunately spice the Spaniards who
broke the Spanish Spanish group of
bought the project but the crisis times
were approaching and where is in the
previous building this pieces were in
iron and stones were yellow when we
reach this stage where my proposal was
to turn the building into another pass a
store don't we bella thorne iron was
substituted by aluminium and the granite
into other material so we worked on the
elements and we came to the conclusion
that it was going to be very expensive
so we decided to use reaches aluminum
platform over with yeah and I built some
Buddhist attribute I built a set showing
the structure there's a result of wine I
need and I didn't know anything about
theatre so at this point until this
one's all these are some will know opera
wielder structures and for the chorus
for the other they use these kinds of
structures and to form cityscapes or
other landscapes OH so these materials
in the set looks like a city so these
structures in would observe people can
see amid the imitation of you looking
what I intended to tell
from the fifth floor nobody can see from
here we use the element in the folded
layers like in the theater building with
the building I wanted to say something
that was alive understand itself we
rehearsed the details for security I
wanted the interior to be in Granite so
to give it a cohesion pearance to use
some of the new classical elements and
spite of the fact that the building was
a modern building in other floors we
show here the concrete but it's too
elegant for me in skiles the first level
so we use the transversal iron that is
immersed in order to do the second
episode stiffness to the materials I
remember when the casa da musica oporto
was built my friend was in staying at
this hotel and witnessed the developing
of that building I decided it was the
same thing as custom da música he told
me not to close the building but I
acetate it back went ahead I continue to
use the aluminum panels the sunset mayor
gave it an effect of sense would have a
great 404 area aspect and in Oporto we
do not have the right climate for that
so um way artists building like this
would not be a ecologically correct
environmentally correct we have the
plaza here water and building the
construction that it opens up into the
north and to the south
their blissful a sort of struts that
hold up the pillars are closed and we on
the sides there are characters and
bathrooms which is the negative now it's
the sunrise side and sunset side the
details of also good day it was probably
a problem and we can see from all the
angles they are false angles these are
not structural this is what we see here
in bronze Oh are lined with the concrete
it's not concrete actually because there
is our and inside it with 16m spirit of
about two quarts of st. Augustine that
the truth is the mirror of truth but is
not saying the truth in this case we
should eat other people so I wanted to
plan office it's not every day that we
owe the same person designs did what it
with the furniture for this building so
the furniture is a continuing of the
building itself they are made out of
aluminum pan dulce we have the cat the
young yo ya candy arrows their lamps and
and in the background the panel it's
closed we have curtains so the air
conditioning unit is an appealing to the
eye and so I use some plastic and it's
like a version of sorts of swatch for
furniture office watch clock watch for
furniture we have the top
this is a fragmentation of blocks of a
block this is the end of the building
which is discarnate from those pieces of
Stratus these are too abstract pieces so
to speak but there is an urban space so
there are some roads or streets more
streets your place bullet with see
support over and the texture of the
building there's a fenestration that you
can see here the plaza the plaza
Oklahoma another another Street what
would have a ploy to kiss you and when I
would look at the building i started
with the seagram java priest why she is
dogma I looked at the low level and the
high level and there was something
missing and I realized that it was was
called her link that made the connection
between the high body and the lower body
eleni with me so I discussed with a
friend of mine a sculpture we started to
study the shape of a sculpture dear
friend of mine and a famous sculpture
and he is now and we tried to find the
proportions he had work sculpture he had
built this kind of structure and this
also functions as a door people walk
below foodarama still fake door and this
is also where the doors and windows it's
a combination of materials that
have negative positive side and the
negative side and so it's a revolving
entrance of a sadism so you make a
rotation episode of Adolphus and the
true of the building appears before you
will see a true pillar in concrete we
see the structure here would foreshadow
which holds the facade and we realize
that it is a false entrance it reminds
me often Backstrom niche that the face
that is saying lies saying the truth
it's the truth about a life following
product dimension able to use the
entrance both men arrival I designed it
fulfill a black egg yolks way it said
mirror it has a mirror effect that
reflects vegetable daughter the
sculpture what about it up in the air
this is the closest popular well there
was the here we'll see the shadows of
event in the pavement vegetable daughter
of the sculpture was a little pudding
them which affected the design which 50
why should use the low and you're
building it's really an inversion out of
high one and the facade is like a cut
inability of us ever it's as if it were
a concealer think about as if it had
been cut right here mr. built off of
their own then I am currently working on
abilene Milan Bombardier based on the
same your theme of negative and positive
space without breath so much box I'm
going to speed up delivery but Florida
this will educate is finishing personal
property for the year in the outskirts
right ah Posada partha was lovely mouth
subjects my suburban area through one of
the most forest areas in the city the
city wanted to invest in housing and in
a hotel a modest hotel
and social housing whether for them
above it that for students and be happy
elderly who have trouble paying their
rent all over my back so it's this is
the extension as far as texture of the
ground the park extends all the way
through here equal pay if this object
and I go close up in these three objects
at the crossroad if the blaze a of these
two hug just for little field trying to
create a center of a European city based
on a crossing Beckham at an intersection
hope you both on the part is the
continuation of the park what piece of
thick web a bicycle your floor is my
valve and these two higher buildings are
like a portal and this one isolated is
the small hotel and here's the plaza yep
between the three buildings figure
here's the site equal that I've got out
there and booking it since we they had
the devil developer that didn't have a
lot of money Bill yes and we worked on
three Heights child adolescent and adult
and how to work with scale was part of
the theme right get poop Lima be careful
seat you fatali their profit so we were
working in with Devan running with
climates with with positive Barcelona
with the Mediterranean climate sir I
wanted to create what those places where
people could look at the sky the shadow
also it was a factor and these Heights
here are the same which allowed us to
tie the buildings and transform the
space into a Plaza space there was a
call you see that's the pity for the
year we did the we tried to do to work
with the chaos around it to create this
Center and his new Plaza they're pretty
for the the new structure
whoop simple out of the periphery if
they can if they'll pass those pathetic
out for that and if it is the activity
of these are movable the cabin walls
whether cut off a shovel so the
architecture ends when the physic where
the facade ends if we met in this
whatever the this this was again was a
project of little nany social project in
a very hot city and they'd if it's a
profit I'd never worked with dildos I
worked with different systems of but he
never windows I never worked with
windows belt she rediscovered windows I
read this text a beautiful text in a
spirit of courage from robert venturi to
rediscover windows and here he explains
that I rediscovered windows I feel
culpable how can you refine we discover
windows in 1995 they fell today so I
designed many different types of Windows
combinations of textures for weeks on
end what was the Volvo fortunately there
was something here in my favor it's that
the building is but in this central part
needed lower centers you wished for the
thing with it had a 50 centimeter with
both or thickness they almost hit you
and the windows at 5043 made sense we
had the historic window and the window
looks like a theater set with these
three to three dimensions via Vitaly it
could be made of metal which the
engineer had told me thankful for the
building to be above the betterment that
usually should the pillars should not be
contained then over the year in other
words they could not be ridiculous
because they'd go them in this direction
so I had to create a certain lattice a
grid a grid that corresponds to this
alignment here thus the openings had to
be done
within the limits of the structure and
here we can see with a poodle if they
think it's that another very interesting
exercise was to do the details and a
zillion brat and to remember again an
exercise I used to do when I was a
student they live but I've emi kadu
Patil Iwakuma mucosa saw that with my
friend season we had to do one detail
which we infinitely the exercise one
detail the infinitely replicated so this
door I've had to work with the theme of
a door in embedded in a wall and here is
a tie to a a closet in the middle of the
awesome and here I utilized this system
ramallah the windows puzzle devilish ml
of Catwoman and then the side the corner
windows to copy a wiki I love like this
motiva be that flora Smith really then
we tried to Delia materialize the box
for cliff wall it's enough we were fired
they said we don't you don't need me
don't need you anyway they didn't never
pay this by the way they were financial
crisis so they sent me but they did send
me these photographs with with the plaza
the pavillion available here you can get
an idea of this street never give a
fifth of the movie mental there with
such that modernism loves these abstract
buildings this notion of plaza stripped
avenue barn doors but the plaza you can
see better here pathetic by the theta
here is the passageway a stairway well
you would have won that breath the back
of a small street and you so much that
this is a stadium I worked with on for
the european championship
without Malone in a city in the north
called bhagavathi it's an ancient Roman
city and it pretty much ends here and at
this area there is a 30 to 40 meter
difference here in the landscape else is
a valley yet both autopilot and this
area is not inhabited because it's a
high-end client in this area here a
camera the what was it without it with
the Chindi City Hall wanted it here in
this area which seem correct to me you
know what I hear there was a quarry
where I went to take some photographs
without understanding of the least about
soccer I decided that this war ii could
go down 30 meters Aoife via and yeah oh
my be like an amphitheater a roman
amphitheatre that only they complete the
vivid it was a completely impossible
idea because a stadium isn't an
amphitheater you need a lot of equipment
in the stadium however when I went back
to my office you feel safe and I thought
about it if you know I thought if I had
15,000 people get up every survivor is
seated on the excavated stone and if we
were to create another bleachers with
another 15,000 feet to bleacher deficit
without phone you could have a 30,000
seats to any other stuff abilities
features were on the actual mount enough
but I am I could have cables which one
across and would support the roof fell
but also likened the Portugal pavilion
with cables physical i was able to do
this construction the problem is a way
for your fifa namitha that the governing
body of South didn't allow me because it
needed more light and ventilation
nowadays they don't require but at the I
at the time they deliberately so noble
project out of the light was over
projected go well
through these holes around the soul I
opened the the roof would have had the
same width of the soccer field Philip I
thought and I could I opened the stadium
so that you could see the surrounding
nature the policy uh I was inspired in
the roof in those Inca bridges with then
have these relative structures and I'm
with wood this was the mountain it had
this shape the papaya and the local art
a parking lot that you come from out
here you park there's a plaza and a set
of ramps that with it that give access
to this area here about human is say to
Millie and the top another player with
like death and people who are from the
city the locals can go by foot by the by
one or another if they want to they can
park it in Drive in park and here there
another set of ramps go and stay away so
if someone makes a mistake and wants to
go the other way around there is under
normally for a huge area where people
can cross underneath for the state way
so that see mother but I going through
here you can go down and up or enter and
go all the way over to the other side
through this room ribs up left achill
here when I see the blueprints well with
Iran if you're going up you can use
these deer was if you're going down you
can go through these ramps for medical
okies phenotype ever sketches he shows
the structure there like ribs yet Hagar
the band wall Travis yes let us hear the
ramps what Buffy bissau here is a Martin
mock-up and please I love my country is
located here buddy
doesn't mean we're very organized though
she will fell so it got to the point
where we discovered but that there
wasn't it enough time to finish it and
to do the construction so they said you
have to do the same thing you have to
google and finish at the same time so
the architects and the engineers decided
to work in the following manner we would
do one but I've had Olivia designed to
excavate the land and mold via the
landscape the path with the everything
de Plaza up there the puzzle down here
the lower chambers the VIP area is the
super VIPs the television air the
journalists I think of and we had all
three keep another team who would work
on the design deals like this other
design so we had not finished yet we had
already molded the landscape accordingly
we had already removed millions of cubic
meters of rock that are all here this
was sold and this helped the published
book to build the day whoa nativity by
the concrete for all this area back
together who is mouth so we were working
on two friends here you'll one were
working on the landscape and the others
the actual design here's the excavation
authority with the notion of having to
Plaza there the area for the journalist
for the tvs for the VIPs axis repair we
see the cut in the rock fish where we
did tests it'll voyage through
explosions and preparations big laugh
they were perpendicular to the actual no
validity Apple fissures in the rock and
we couldn't contradict this so one we
went to the side that abut of the cuts
were parallel to the fissures and it
began to fall so we began to put
supports
and with fully that 25 meters we decided
to try to strengthen the rock here are
some mountain climbers without my bed
and we worked in the following manner I
learned this throughout the years uh we
they needed to know how we could open
here this area to allow the passage of
course of the corridors that would serve
each level and they needed the we needed
these partnerships the goethals for the
engineers with you have a world and we
have to believe the disk we descend they
decided it could be this way all working
on the maximum limits after two hours
these design one else Doug we were
working day and night so the idea was
architects engineers architects
engineers looks like it's back and forth
back and forth and then striking the
actual instruction about anyway we
practically finished is that we actually
built this mock-up quicker this model in
aluminium to see how the parts work
together so they also use the actual
constructions of tomato by gravity on
the kill here's the first bleachers by
few and here we see the circles i
mentioned especially look at the
negative places for these for the beams
to actually place the corridors the
platforms what if you ask the flawtl f
these are the coordinates welcome
sometimes they were like this sometimes
contrary about that this bleachers was
finished but they were following we
began some work on that room that I that
space I told you where you can put
underneath good through those ramps and
then go up these staircases and the
mid-level volley at avoid peak at these
is a won't go into much detail here but
these are access areas
the stadium atiba hoof that the public
had contacts the politicians the journey
is the players the neighbors yes but I'm
all political but there's a man where do
they have to here's the locker room they
have to go down to the locker room to
give them the trophy in the journalists
the players can all a sable here
everyone comes through this system of
elevators and escalators and stairways
and they all meet here in this room here
to deliver the trophy LOL compliation
here or the fabricated a few handles
take theta where I would Bluetooth it is
what else might we'll see that happen
when those says not close in case of
fire or are these type of math and he's
I also for draining but little
problematic cement wall of the
availability of salt David here is the
ventilation of actuation thanks about
the PFF of that and I high-powered cable
electrical cable I don't know why I've
always thought of you email without it I
sort of Aquila that dudes would all be
there to nagios but they're going to
rather than they went to well here's the
superior the high Plaza you've got an
interesting thing to observe is that the
plaza should continue on to the roof I
thought that would be interesting you
have a fear the stairs represent
negative space but I said when it
started out building I thought I can
remove these the shadows and allow the
rain and the light to enter the double
click and here we began the construction
of a gallop oil oh the feature here is
the bank gaba he passed it was still I
guess you got up of the data and here if
we could after this is the member the
quarry where I took those photos
initially
favorite Laura we equal Fiona at the
back a vegetable and these walls these
stone walls of the fabric cut through
here it is your style and it goes into
the stone and we left this negative
space here that they've got to put
cables those follada theme so this works
in the following manner a battery of
authority falls on this stone and
they're held would I cables mesh with
him him 20 centimeters subscale of
weather and they can they cannot they
can sustain winds of up to town
kilometers without waiving significant
your profit or what scares the plaza
this tech is FFF and here are those
pieces that hold up by the larvae and
here's the landscape the valley or for
the fourth jellyfish by a lawful and
there's pain in the back effective on
pathetic available to the fender here
are the double the businesses always two
cables so cool kappa hope thou they're
placed here you poked out here's where
the cable enters will put all fills up
Adam a Peruvian using the the rock as an
anchor suspend Ont be there are these
anti vibrating with a pool filled with
us is when the wind condition starts to
look at the lower they they swing and
they will counterbalance the waving of
the tables by later and they don't hear
a was caticlan dolls aluminum panels
it's leave them for God and these pieces
can actually slide along the cables
pffff and we finished the roof of the
web it over I was weird to the water go
you have to be i would spend so much
money the air to suspend the roof with
cables what if you couldn't put a
couldn't put some real life here
so the water is accumulates in khane up
in a train here and is projected out
through this piece here with welcome to
that which is like a mobility of thing I
wanna take a loose positively co-op it's
a and here's in vertical you light
almost if they people get a perspective
of the wall I believe that I knew that
television was so important for soccer
and a stadium is almost like a studio
for TV they have to have 2,000 watts of
light and has to be as vertical as
possible to light foot for television a
perfect good good move Oh fastball
couple 2030 premiere from what allows
the velocity of the water to be always
the same here's the scale of the stadium
at 30 meters approximately and weezer
this is 26 it's one single metal piece
was it that it projects on it Divya
water will wake that it's all good and
here's a screen that was necessary to
have to since we only had two batches
after the double won't it's does not
touch anything at standing it's years
one small salad ship the woods guy
ambassa still after dating my hot with
all the pillars have momentum that I
like to to maintain the angles of the
roof physic here will involve area we
see this there's one rule here which is
that the pillars their own always
tangential no quarto they never cut the
pavement and it really that a little bit
to try to create the monumental affect
the Olivia this creates a living I don't
know how you would say this say that is
yet
a limit the Piron luminous effect Bob's
father Iowa here's with water drains it
is collected here and here's what the
light comes through its walls are better
if everythings modules are ready to the
tangent cases here in metal hit me up if
you go and all day and I want to go up
there are elevators there's bathroom you
stay up with that and this is the end of
the state is Beth with these types of
Japanese and shoes a HEPA rabbits those
that go elephant both Java and then you
can get at the stairs and those that go
down to go to the other features the way
the corso socket is complete thing that
isn't hey there were three rules that we
had to cut I one fateful all these
points had to be ten declared earlier so
that this line left epithelia that
always be maintained on the staircase
and the circles would always have the
same effect to guarantee continuity in
the hallway so this was one of the
effects we you can see he i leave it at
that was the myth they'll endemic and
the drama without had to work on the
facade how to work on the facade of the
stadium else killa a stadium ism like a
machine she got your logic and logic
told us that this model should have
steers so I did a sculpture if they
don't live together they are stairs like
that no one can use or also fall so
they're very elegant so together faith
and they are like a airplane wing
they're attached here they look like
they're always in the same operation but
they get bigger and bigger like a
in wing to the fourth every door here
exist without the multi-device these
doors have to be seen from far away they
have to accommodate to corral chief ever
from value here when the middle populate
that well I'm you're right okay but the
spa fish for the earth here's the
inferior than lower space here's the
little canal canal so and the
construction and here's the man using
the maximum data give up as good as the
garages stata helva you dip the cans you
asked if these prompted without that it
was so I think it did we show that there
can't be continuity when I did this
while I was building the stadium i went
to leave this place but a grease and i
found tiny wonderful things the
stadium's it will provide a walk or
close here is the NEPA woods because I
call for you that gives a certain
comfort and it also has an acoustic
effect and behind that like a theater
set is the landscape though the second
without thing agric guy is the water
can't sit at the veil I'm directly go
into the stadium are also create a
cataract into this settlin so the
intelligence of the Greeks who are now
unfortunate crisis they would collect
the water in each of these levels every
level is slightly on behind backwards
which collects the waters and canals and
here are the students and it's directed
downwards and here is where the water is
collected and then drained out it's a
marvelous construction if they vitac a
public Oh marvelous Valley this is one
of the areas of the state and I most
likely but then
because this is a role I I hate this
notion that what is concrete AdWords
green is good water clock can be natural
or man-made here it's cut every half a
meter nature never exists in the state's
feel icky so the rock that came out of
here we used artificial estonia's here
so they live next side by side and
create an interesting composition and
there is a way it's like one came out of
here and it was placed you and they work
side by side it's also theaters but I
with that so they need each other to
support those 200 kilometer wins whoa
Paul a cadet here's a game that scream
who I was telling you about it's not a
suspended almost vertical light of a
theater it's a severe the rock which
creates great acoustics imagining what
ethical lead active f when this Hill is
we build up with all the trees this will
look like a wooded section like a forest
you'll see the forest and you'll see the
mountains here back here's the Braga
bleacher a very vertical that what s the
fish and that's the architects quality
was it was prophesied yet stopped at a
fish i fulfill not this said there's a
risk that this will be used for the
european champion and i have to praise
the city of braga their City Hall we're
very afraid we weren't going to do it we
managed to end her cisely on the
thirty-first of December on the deadline
so my client and I we worked together
with the engineers to comply with the
deadline and if this had not taken this
we would have been flogged yes and we
would have been run out of town you say
that with a theory though we became
heroes and left and this city is very
proud of the stadium the stadium no
longer belongs it doesn't belong to me
it's not my design
and now it belongs to the collected over
the city that's the best thing that
could ever happen architect the
universities do exercises based on this
stadium and students also like this I
love the fact that the students are
designing based on the state malkova but
not only the students were properly
imagined which have the image of the
stadium it's always busy that has
entered the imagination of the
population this is the best that could
ever happen to an architect
love is a physical memory and now if
you'd like to ask questions
that was completely spectacular boy
crumpler them into spectacle at a second
example soon we have a little time for
Question our stem cigar on perdido para
preguntar I'm se que están todo certain
tent are incorporated exeter than the
South Africa Columbia say those used to
dance with the mic that would be very
helpful
while people are lining up I hope we get
some people to line up that would be
great or I'm going to have to call on
people I do that too maybe I'll ask a
quick question I'm adding my depth here
I don't think that I just appreciated
this enormously I wish you were
designing the stadium that's now going
up in Brooklyn New York because this
what whatever you did I think we could
benefit dramatically from your amazing
work so I understand what you did
particularly for the stadium you were in
an open area and then you and there was
one particular project also that you
design that was in a city when you have
to design in a highly a dense populated
area do you take into account the
streetscape or the activity that's going
on in that area the way you did in the
natural spaces which you know you just
made it more beautiful with your
structure how do you do that in the city
in the more densely populated areas he
says at the mental gusto a procura
that's exactly what I'm trying to do
there is bidding to build Allison
stadium and the one in Zurich I didn't
win the one in 03 good the law son but I
in Zurich I I want to build three
structure with three windows looking
into the mountain and I am trying to
integrate that landscape with the city
and with the lake that's Eureka and so
the city changes and the designer has to
change as well question introduce
yourself please and I think that would
be helpful sure mba 2012
I'm Portuguese as well so I kind of
wonder whether i should ask the question
in portuguese are in English and but the
question is the following and when he
designed the museum the museum of Paula
hey did Elias did you interact with
Paola and get her inspiration in the
design or you did it intellectually
without her input no well I talked twice
i distilled with paula rego and that was
enough because as she said she didn't
like it that much she explained to me
renault clio know that she didn't want
the museum and i want to london and
rumors Waka sat down and talked and she
said she wanted more of her house and
she gave me examples of what she liked
was showing the structures in London and
I understood what she wanted and i sent
a chance to her and she said ok but i
wasn't as if dating because portugal has
so many great architects so it was a big
responsibility for me and i told her
that i agreed but when we start the
construction that is going to become a
problem but she packed it she wrote a
letter to you congratulating me on my
ideas but I acted autonomously by myself
architecture has to be done in that way
the architect cannot do anything against
the wishes of the client it cannot
demand that the client has something
built in their place and setting that
idiot she doesn't like and the reverse
also applies you cannot force in nature
things and if it does that then it he
loses interest even with interest on the
project who knows what will happen
but if you are not interested enough and
you'll continue to insist what can
happen so she was a great client was
released and then the media the museum
is called Casa de studies the house of
histories so it did they they told
stories a lot of stories but its
inventions it's abrogated by them and
there are attributes and there are
oceans but architecture is like a nice
burger it's salad it's ice cold mr.
demora good evening my name is Jacob
liceo de 2012 Columbia Business School
and the question that I have in building
up upon the prior question pertains to
the often contentious relationship
between the architects and commercial
developers can you reflect upon your
private commissions and talk about the
challenges that exist between the
architect who may see himself or herself
as the artiste and the owner in the
future going forward of a particular
design in a particular work and the
commercial relate and a commercial
developer that is driven by other
considerations how what challenges have
you faced and how have you overcome them
what obsessed with the whole process in
architecture faces problems and i'm glad
that happens because that demands
certain things from the architect
because when the work is linear and
simple we are near mediocrity so we have
to create drama we have to create a
certain term mode so that the architect
to find motivation the biggest problem
today to tell you the truth for the
architect is not with the developers are
the engineers it's when the client and
the proprietor for reasons and i'm
talking about the situation in my
control but I and I said I love my
country but the problem is that society
we're on the those who hold the power
religious and political power do not
give up their ownership Roger buildings
and many times they do not have the
resources they don't have the time or
the money issues and then they ask us
are the impossible so they create time
pressure and problems arise and
sometimes they change the materials
because there's not enough money there
are subsidies from the EU the problems
with the developers today with the
existing crisis throughout Europe and
especially in vegetable a developer
wants to finish the the building but he
is not interested in doing something I
have done so to make the money but he
has to count the coins for the cost of
construction they bid with a budget that
is almost negative but they are they
we'll try to recover that investment by
using other errors that the engineer are
the architect made it's almost a problem
of survival I would say I am open to bid
as long as they are serious well as I
explained for the Stadio and in mid
construction during the construction of
stadium I'll make some changes in terms
of the lighting and water and so forth
and we have to have accounting and
submission for police work in this case
that the engineer we drew the concrete
structures to make openings and that to
make it less expensive and we could buy
the furniture with that money so our
relationship the developers propane is
not bad it's the owner that sometimes it
has funding problems I don't know if I
answer to your question motorboating are
so architetto a luna dude program EG
designer bonus me pregunta SI architects
cuando sea or hey sir be its reward
recipe of supreme you want to risk an OG
sic it for Joe gardeners machetes new
business journal's that at some point
the the time of the super or star
architects was finished and my question
goes regards that and your process of
design and work and your idea of
craftsman's craftsmanship and
development of each product
it's a small question no no it's a big
question that's what I'm pro cosmos
product work with I I don't exactly
agree because the authority to the
feather home architecture is going to
pop with them stars when the Pope would
call celebrities laughs Cynthia the to
st. Peter's RV or Leonardo da Vinci when
he would go to France by the way there
was the FF he was a celebrity so when
the dan de louvre tender in the end of
the day the frig Eddie trunk Ulla
successfully the effort for it is a in
the end right when I talking about it
King so for instance in the 20th century
we had meet around the President of the
Republic and he had they are all the big
projects in the progress and not even
before Pritzker the other Pritzker's
woman they were not celebrities and I am
NOT modest romantic against celebrities
I was living in a country where I did
not have the opportunity to stand out as
a celebrity famous I would take the
opportunity if it was offered to me I
don't have false modesty I spent my life
building houses so I need to UM take
advantage of the opportunity I didn't
have any member of my family who was an
architect I didn't belong to any
political party I was not politically
correct I was building houses and
participating in tenders so working with
architects
the first project that is was offered to
me was this tower I started with one
level until and i went up to 23 floors
and i didn't used to design the windows
and then in barcelona I'd built such as
with a lot of Windows still about the
celebrities this perception that there
was a commercial world and narcissistic
belonging to the celebrities that now is
going to change maybe it will change but
not for the same reasons I built this
stadium because the city authority are
called me to ask me for the telephone
number of Calatrava if I had college at
this number yoga school i replied no i
don't have it the sperry but wait a
minute Cesar works of my office and I'm
going to go and dust yeah because they
worked together for a civilian in Lisbon
and a railway station and i told him i
know that Cesar has the phone and I call
you back and instead but why would they
deputy mayor said we are going to build
a stadium and what's available we asked
for the budget for a budget from foster
it was in braga secure again the north
of Portugal and we always thought it was
too expensive and also we were offended
in addition to the high price the design
the tragedies like a Wembley there
wembley stadium lights like a copy we
so because it's so expensive they went
to ask calatrava and I told him well
Cara Travis twenty percent more
expensive than Forrester and for this
and for that and it said so what should
I do what's your position Andy asked me
what about yourself don't you want to do
that and I thought I do for you think
that's how the stadium was born replaces
Volusia a site are my ultima pregunta
maizena pregunta hello my name is
Katherine Oh Mon Ami i'm currently a
student in the engineering school 2012
my question actually is about what
inspires you through your career as an
architect they've probably been loves
about what you want to do to face a
problem and what do you go to in order
to get the answer I went through a lot
of problems but it's not a question of
inspiration that oh it's the same thing
as asking a girl writer wide your right
or a painter what you painter or a
photographer why do you photograph I
think that it's something that likened
to a Ambrose to a drive when there is
not a commission for a work will feel a
drive and user group and people get
weird tired of the world and one day
they are someone asked me why are you an
architect I didn't know what to answer
him and I said I am an architect because
I said because I think God did not
create the world too well she did not
rest on the seventh day because he
didn't think about how we cross the
rivers we have to build the bridges and
if we didn't have
I was warming a house we could not live
properly and i think that is a sense of
injustice of something missing they will
drive to do something better to perfect
yourself and a journalist once published
a headline that in a maligned way God
must not have arrested in West case that
shows herself because I think that it is
because it's not in the history of
classical architecture the rules were
that the artist should be inspired by
nature that was based in Aristotle and
so forth to the gunt with is so live in
nature disgaea and you knowed it and
learned the rules if we learned the
rules of nature we can transpose them
and try to approximate nature until
something brilliant came up which was
called the modernist movement and the
famous rainbow sense which said we must
be absolutely modern and created
something contrary nature as should
imitate art it flipped it on a tell you
that is the most interesting approach
will go through an area and say as i was
walking if i was walking through a space
and a mountain I was in France and
Suzanne had pointed the same mountain 20
or 30 times and one thing that mountain
is not a mountain anymore it just says
I'm Betty Ann we said it had I forget
the name of it now that something
whether so when teacher tries to copy
art
that's what inspires us to build a
better world and this is true in other
disciplines to Laura thank you for
sharing your intelligent inspirational
and dramatic designs with us I hope we
see more of you in New York and in the
United States we certainly could use
your intelligent design it's a pleasure